[Musique]
la colère comme ici à granville dans la
manche les pêcheurs français attendent
leur licence peuvent pêcher eu
l'autorisation de pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques après le break site l'ombre
en a accordé 210 la france en réclame
200 44 de plus pour cent des lits sont
fermés faute de personnel depuis la
crise sanitaire le problème de manque de
lits ne s'est pas améliorée bien au
contraire il manque quasiment 50% des
licences auquel nous avons droit c'est
une situation qui n'est pas acceptable
et je le dis clairement notre patience a
atteint ses limites aujourd'hui ne
laisserons pas la grande bretagne
s'essuyer les pieds sur l'accord brésil
qui a été conclu si une simple j'ai lu
le pouvait guérir du coup ville c'est
l'espoir que promet un laboratoire
américain le groupe pharmaceutique merck
développe un antiviral à prendre par
voie orale dès que les patients sont
positifs ils diviserait par deux les
risques d'hospitalisation
la france en a commandé s'est positionné
très tôt en précommande qui est j'ai
confirmé des commandes cinquante mille
doses de ce médicament vont être livrés
à la france a compté des derniers jours
de novembre des premiers jours de
décembre les violences se sont prolongés
jusque tard dans la nuit à alençon tirs
de mortiers d'artifice contre la police
invectives hier à partir de 23 heures le
quartier perseigne s'est embrasée on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas
une véritable volonté de lutter contre
la délinquance parce que on parle
aujourd'hui de ce quartier on a beaucoup
parlé d'un autre quartier en plein coeur
de ville qui s'appelle la place gabriel
péri où il ya un espèce de marché
sauvage qui s'est installée les
habitants découvrent des épaves encore
fumantes une quinzaine de véhicules ont
été incendiés parmi les nombreux
enseignements de cette étude il y à vous
laver ni la droitisation de la société
française est une tendance longue
aujourd'hui 37 % des électeurs se disent
eux mêmes de droite c'est moins c'était
moins d'un tiers il ya trois ans tandis
que la gauche ne représentent plus que
20 % des électeurs ils sont environ 300
à scander des slogans contre eric
zemmour
en français
mais aussi en basse
laissez nous chasser laissez-nous est
fier de notre histoire et de nos moeurs
laissez nous tenir la porte à une femme
laissez nous regarder un bon film
d'audiard laissez-nous cette insolence
française dont nous sommes si fiers je
vois qu'il ya là un danger non pas pour
qu'il soit élu soyons clairs il ne peut
pas être élu sur ce programme et sur
cette personnalité parce qu'ils disent
parce qu'ils divisent parce qu'ils le
brutalise parce que il ya une
instrumentalisation de l'histoire parce
qu'il divise même entre les femmes et
les hommes messieurs homosexuels et je
vote pour vous
emmerde est ce que vous pensez de ce
comité d'accueil on ne peut pas parler
avec ces gens pour marine le pen je
l'appelais je la plains de devoir
reprendre de parler comme marlène
schiappa de parler comme la gauche de
parler comme les féministes je la plains
de devoir reprendre des arguments mais
vous savez j'avais été le premier à le
dire et à le diagnostic et c'est une
femme de gauche quand vous voyez que
monsieur zemmour dit que madame le pen
est de gauche on se dit que là qu'elle
est au niveau de la dérive et donc c'est
une dérive à l'inter de ma famille
politique que je combats et règlements
passe plus de temps à taper sur la la la
première opposante emmanuel macron qui
n'a pour le coup aucune responsabilité
dans la situation du pays qu'à taper sur
emmanuel d'un concert devient
franchement un peu suspect 379 personnes
sont mortes en prenant des selphy dans
le monde sur les dernières années c'est
une étude extrêmement sérieuse il suffit
de voir les trois causes principales de
ces décès les chutes dans le vide en
première position les moyens de
transport invitera en voiture et les
noyades les chercheurs font une carte
mondiale des spots les plus
accidentogènes parcelles fille et arrive
en tête les chutes du niagara
le grand canyon donc aux états unis ou
encore le taj mahal